découvrir le sénat ses acteurs ses
missions le palais du luxembourg reçoit
les élus locaux de toute la france
une découverte et une volonté d'échangé
à l'occasion du 100ème congrès des
maires il ya une certaine unanimité il
ya une certaine solidarité entre les
élus qu'ils soient du bloc communal
qu'il soit du niveau national les élus
les parlementaires effectivement nous
avons tous la même motivation nous avons
tous la même passion pour défendre nos
territoires
on est en attente d'un certain nombre de
réponses il ya un climat de confiance
malgré tout mais on a besoin d'avoir un
certain nombre de réponses par rapport à
la ruralité particulièrement où le
président s'était exprimé sur sa volonté
de prendre en compte la ruralité et on a
beaucoup d'attentes à ce niveau là un
congrès annoncée comme tendues entre
représentants des collectivités le
gouvernement
gérard larcher président du sénat est
élu yvelinois apporte son soutien aux
élus locaux notamment sur la question de
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
la taxe d'habitation était un des sujets
et voilà pourquoi j'ai proposé qu'on
travaille tout son sens à la mise en
place d'une fiscalité locale qui
permette de préserver le lien service
dans une commune où une interco citoyens
élus locaux qui décident au travers
d'une fiscalité locale nous avons avec
sophie primas et mes autres
collectionneurs visite est quasiment
toutes les communes certaines deux fois
depuis le printemps
c'est l'occasion d'entendre à la fois
les interrogations mais aussi les
espérances des communes des yvelines
le congrès des maires se tient jusqu'au
23 novembre près de 4000 élus sont
accueillis au sénat d'ici jeudi